our chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett is here with a look at the next
step in the president's effort to build
a wall major good more good morning
everybody before we get to the next step
let's stay on this step this deal what
did the president get after all of this
activity the worst deal of of all the
ones ever put before him I mean we
should take this moment to identify that
the great deal maker delt himself the
worst possible hand of all of them given
to him by Congress Republican or
Democrat but he has no choice he has to
take it very likely means he's going to
sign it according to all those who are
closest to him once he signs it we'll
know for sure but this is going to be
the worst of the deals presented to him
because it's the smallest dollar amount
he had a much larger dollar amount a
year ago even three or four months ago
and is that because Congress railroaded
the president or is it because the
president is fatigued after the longest
partial government shutdown nobody wants
to go into that box canyon again
politically or from a matter of policy
so the president gave the appropriators
space to do this deal appropriate has
made the deal that they could make and
said here it is mr. president take it or
leave it will have to take it he's also
dangled another option and that's an
emergency declaration how likely could
that happen
I think it's more likely than not the
president will say look I respected the
congressional process Congress is
dysfunctional I've told the country that
repeatedly and I'm now going to use at
least some emergency powers to get some
money because I've identified this as a
national priority
Congress did not meet my requirements I
will use other tools to achieve that
that will try to address the criticism
he knows will come from the right when
some credit presidents have done that
same thing whatever what's the
Republican reaction bit hostile that you
are overstepping your grounds and you
should respect the congressional process
that's why the president's waited so
long hold it in abeyance to say look I
gave this process time I'm not satisfied
I'm gonna go another route speaker
Pelosi also said there wouldn't be one
dollar right there it kind of wall and
there is money they stopped the wall and
look we're really getting hung up
because the president's rhetoric made us
get hung up on in 2016
wall concrete whatever look the experts
do say there areas that need
reinforcement that's a legitimate public
policy issue the president's pursuing
that he's just not getting nearly as
much as he wants and Democrats also know
that there is nothing actually immoral
about part of fan
seeing that's reinforced that protects
the border and can we just be clear
decades Congress Democratic Republican
and presidents have all kicked the can
down the road on legitimate immigration
reform right there anything new or
different in this bill that would
address what is a problem facing this
country about dealing with illegal
immigrants in the country whether it's
putting them on temporary green cards or
anything daca anything in this a simple
answer is no however on the other side
of this there must come the realization
that even with a president who has the
most aggressive border security rhetoric
of any president in the last 30 to 40
years you still can't get this big
border wall that shows you the limits of
our political legislative process
doesn't he use all of that political
power it's going to be just some real
integration X failures that's gonna be
the next phase of this because on the
other side of this worse deal imaginable
he's going to have to come up with a new
approach to immigration and it's going
to have to be bigger and a broader
aperture his own companies I mean he'd
had illegal immigrants working in his
companies they had to fire them he
should know his own business knows that
there's a problem here you say it's the
worst deal that he could have possibly
gotten isn't gonna sit well with him so
it'll be interesting to see no it's not
but it forces him to reconcile himself
to the legislative process you do that
then you make different strategic
decisions establish different priorities
another shutdown wouldn't look good for
his poll numbers either it would not
which are in a better shape than they've
been recently major thank you
always pleasure